when I was a kid every time we had
oranges my dad would always peel this
little orange man into the skin as he
was cutting them for us which is quite
fun really I mean like get to have like
a little companion why would he do that
was it to encourage you to eat because
he liked you know what I'm actually I'm
actually allergic to oranges as well so
it'd be all nice and fun until I was
sick but the mathematical idea of
peeling a two-dimensional object into
the surface of the sphere it stuck with
you thunk with me I think I've lost my
place now okay when we had like like
need another arm the reason I wanted to
show you this was because I was always
something a little bit annoying about
the orange man it's like his legs coming
off now ah wait wait
imagine you don't see that bit okay no
it kind of works it kind of works right
kind of way see there you go he's sort
of that I took his leg off well whatever
he's kind of cool like this little
orange guy it's more like a starfish
really here's one okay
my only one was a bit better and my
practice one was a bit better and this
is a fresher orange I think that's my
problem I just realized that you own I
know exactly the problem is they even
though you got this kind of quite fun
little guy you can never get him to sit
flat on the desk you can never quite get
him to like lay perfectly flat
especially not without really you know
deforming the orange bill and there's a
reason for that and the reason is
something called the Gaussian curvature
now Gaussian curvature is a number that
describes how curvier surface is and
it's made up of two things multiplied
together one is how the surface curves
in one direction and the second number
is how it curves in the perpendicular
direction you multiply those two
together to get the Gaussian curvature
no matter how you'd bend a surface the
Gaussian curvature will always stay the
same so here with an orange it's
positive in that direction positive in
that direction but so whatever you do to
the surface of an orange it always has
to have some kind of a
and away from you you actually want your
orange man to lie flat on a
two-dimensional surface which has zero
Gaussian curvature there's no way that
two positive numbers can ever multiply
together to make zero and that doesn't
really matter so much when you're
talking about orange peels or the orange
men but it does matter when you really
want to make the surface of a sphere lie
flat on a two-dimensional surface like
when you're trying to make a map of that
oh ok so one option that you've got if
you wanted to effectively peel the
surface of the earth to make a map is to
cut up all sorts of slits like this
unfurl them kind of like this and then
squish it as literal as possible so I am
still you will end up with these kind of
deformations the skin deforming as you
squish it down especially at the ends
they're not really gonna match together
very well
but you've kind of got a sort of flat
shape that came from the surface of your
sphere and that really is the idea
behind dude Hummel sign projection which
sometimes gets nicknamed the orange peel
projection and kind of see why it does a
good job it's certainly flat but you
have to squish quite a lot of this to
get it into the right place so this map
here doesn't preserve Direction very
well and also it's not going to be
particularly useful for navigating I
mean you're kind of coming off here and
there's a massive gap it's just not very
nice not particularly nice so this is a
very squished at the top so if you kind
of look at the top here the shape of the
of the land of the coast doesn't quite
match the shape that you get up here but
also actually if you sort of imagine
folding this round into three dimensions
and stitching it back together you
wouldn't get a spherical shape so you
can kind of see how things have been
literally ah sort of squished down
effectively this isn't gonna work very
well is it not at the well so there are
a few different options here but none of
them are gonna get you completely around
the problem of transforming the surface
of a sphere into a flat two-dimensional
space so one option is you could say
okay well around the equator these
squares have last shoes and longitude
are quite square and that's quite nice
you want to try and keep that so when
you go up the top maybe you say okay
well why don't we deform these areas so
that they're always nice neat rectangle
or by the time it gets to these paper
for that you end up with something that
looks like the equirectangular
projection here which is certainly the
world and it's you know successfully on
two dimensions but the problem with this
one is that direction goes all over the
place here so if you take one of the
ones near the North Pole
this line here is actually really tiny
when it is on the globe so if you want
to get from one corner of this to the
other you'd end up going in like this
very weird part it's not very good for
navigation so that leads to the map that
probably most of us know which is made
by in Spain it's taken a big sheet of
paper and forming a cylinder around your
globe you know you can imagine that
you've got a light on the inside of this
globe and that's right in the center and
shining outwards and then if you trace a
shadow of the land on the paper as it
was wrapped in a cylinder around you
would end up with the Mercator
projection this is what Google Maps uses
and it does a really good job especially
keeping the shape of the countries quite
nicely and also in preserving direction
so this is really good for navigation if
you want to get from London to Brazil
you can just head in a straight line it
might not be the shortest way to get
there but you know you're gonna get
there so that's kind of why the Mercator
map projection is point and handy the
only problem about Mercator because
you're using a cylinder things are going
to be distorted at the poles much more
than they're distorted at the equator
and as a result the area of different
land masses ends up being completely
completely mucked out completely skewed
so if you look on the Mercator map
Greenland and Africa look roughly the
same size but when you look on the globe
Africa is absolutely bloody massive and
Greenland is teeny-tiny so excuse your
perceptions altogether another one is
that Australia sitting just below the
equator the top it is anyway is actually
the same size of the entirety of bloody
euro
on the real globe but I think it just
ends up you get a bit distorted when you
look at things on a Mercator map there's
still a problem here right McKay tis not
perfect there's always going to be a
problem and I spotted something isn't
it's an a paper that I've liked for a
long time it's this paper here it's
called orange peels and Fresnel
integrals and essentially in this paper
they show that if you peel an orange in
a spiral and then lay it flat on a table
- very nice things happen first off as
you're number of loops in your spiral
tends to infinity the shape that it
makes on the table tends to a Euler
spiral this is very very beautiful neat
mathematical shape where the curvature
changes linearly as you move along it
really it's just a lovely idea also the
amount that your orange peel has to
deform to lie flat on the table tends to
0 as your number of loops in your spiral
tends to infinity so I think we've
missed a trick here because I think that
this is what map should look like I
think that we should have we should
prioritize mathematical beauty over
geographical practicality what is it
doing that other maps aren't doing well
it's not gonna be deformed all of the
other maps are deformed in some way and
also it's Aguila spiral brainy one what
do you want so this is the Euler spiral
map a new way of map can we do this I
don't see why not
I reckon we can cut this on up and see
what happens like like the way you would
peel an orange right like if you were
doing a spiral in an orange they start
at the top and then just wind your way
down I'm just gonna do it on the earth
so at the top more and more way down why
not
whatever you doing ok ok these do a risk
assessment ready okay get it hit what's
your plan you're gonna hit the same
hideous what about each line of latitude
you hit the seam through Russia ok
so ideally you'd be doing this really
really fine but yeah I mean we've only
got betting on this room but for another
hour
[Music]
hence wax
turns out the world's really big readily
what's the brainy Lucy it's literally
paradise on the ruins in the Rose it
completely does is unbelievable
No
[Music]
I don't know if I'm gonna I think I need
to ask a bit further escape oh I missed
it technically I missed it yeah
basically
and do you want to zealand you know i
think i'm gonna preserve it
[Music]
I mean that lets me second out we should
both have bad things to do that I'm
brainy oh my god just a much worth it
telling you what a room big enough okay
so you have to remember I have done a
finite number of spirals and the real
you limit protection as it's now gonna
be called would have an infinite number
it's worth it though Brady for the
mathematical beauty that will unfold
okay and do the other spiral honor I
think when I went to university system
Merce this is not how I almost my life
right that circle at roughly the same
size at the other one
[Music]
yeah but you like it
almost almost naturally this kind of
works this kind of works as a map I
think people could get used to this
so you brainy it doesn't mean you know
if you're in sort of Paris and you want
to go to Vienna you're fine but if you
want to go north to North to London you
do have to do an entire lap of the globe
but you know simple sacrifice so if you
had n loops on your globe so with one of
these barrels are is like one over N
this Defamation reduces like one over N
squared so you know you're gaining the
more loops you have the more you gain I
think as a map projection you know this
is mathematically beautiful if
geographically impractical it's Lewton
check out these problems and questions
all of them involve the Earth Maps
Globes
they're questions that I really hope you
get your head around the stuff in
today's video and all of them are on
brilliant org who are the supporter of
today's video
now brilliant full of quizzes and
courses and puzzles on all sorts of
subjects from mathematics and science
but don't feel intimidated don't think
they're trying to test you or make you
feel dumb this is all about changing the
way you think making you smarter and
better at attacking problems but if you
don't know the answer that's fine
there's no judgement in fact you can go
and read a whole bunch of people talking
about how they would have attacked the
problem real mind broadening stuff now
go to brilliant org slash numberphile to
check out all the stuff there's loads of
stuff on the site for free but if you
want to sign up for the Premium
Membership you'll get 20% off if you use
slash numberphile now thanks to
brilliant for trying to make the world a
smarter place
hey and speaking of planet Earth why
don't you check out Hannah's latest book
it's called hello world I'll include a
link down in the show notes along with a
brilliant link she did work out all
right
[Music]